lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
continuar con el tema de movimiento
circular uniforme en particular veremos
el concepto de período que denotamos con
la letra t mayúscula y otro concepto muy
relacionado con el periodo la frecuencia
que denotamos con la letra f minúscula
quizá ustedes ya hayan visto estos
conceptos pero vamos a asegurarnos de
que los comprenden en el contexto de la
velocidad angular particularmente con la
magnitud de la velocidad angular que ya
vimos que se denota con la letra griega
o mega minúscula y ya que no tiene la
flecha arriba sabemos que es la magnitud
de la velocidad angular primero veamos
que es el periodo y qué es la frecuencia
el periodo es la cantidad de tiempo
necesario para completar un ciclo y si
hablamos del movimiento circular
uniforme un ciclo se refiere al tiempo
que tarda este objeto en dar una vuelta
completa a este círculo podemos
imaginarlo como una pelota atada con una
cuerda a un punto de rotación que se
mueve con una rapidez uniforme por
ejemplo si tenemos un periodo de un
segundo
esta pelota se moverá así un segundo dos
segundos tres segundos cuatro segundos
esto sería un periodo de un segundo si
tenemos un periodo de dos segundos esta
pelota se movería a la mitad de la
velocidad un segundo dos segundos tres
segundos cuatro segundos cinco segundos
seis segundos y si ahora el periodo
fuera de medio segundo la pelota se
movería así un segundo dos segundos
termina un ciclo completo en medio
segundo la unidad del periodo es el
segundo es una unidad de tiempo y que es
la frecuencia es el recíproco del
periodo así que la frecuencia es igual a
1 entre el periodo una forma de pensar
en el periodo es preguntándonos cuántos
ciclos se recorren en un segundo el
periodo es igual a cuántos segundos se
necesitan para completar un ciclo y la
frecuencia es la cantidad de ciclos que
se recorren en un segundo por ejemplo si
se recorren dos ciclos en un segundo un
segundo dos segundos
segundos la frecuencia es de dos ciclos
por segundo las unidades de la
frecuencia a veces se indican como el
inverso del segundo o también se usa la
abreviatura h mayúscula z minúscula que
significa hertz a veces a los hertz se
les llama ciclos por segundo las
unidades del periodo se pueden ver como
segundos por ciclo y la frecuencia son
ciclos por segundo con esto en mente
veamos si podemos relacionar estas ideas
con la magnitud de la velocidad angular
digamos que la magnitud de la velocidad
angular speed radiales por segundo cuál
será el periodo pausa en el vídeo y
traten de encontrar la respuesta vamos a
resolverlo juntos esta pelota va a
recorrer irradian es cada segundo cuánto
tiempo le llevará a recorrer dos y
radiant es recuerden que una rotación
completa son dos radiales si recorre
irradian es en un segundo tardará dos
segundos en recorrer dos y radiant es
aquí el periodo es de dos segundos
esto lo resolvimos intuitivamente pero
como podemos manipular
para obtener esto bueno para completar
una rotación hay que recorrer dos
radiales que es lo que mide un ciclo
completo y esto lo dividimos entre el
valor de la velocidad angular por lo que
en este caso lo dividimos entre pi
radiales por segundo tenemos la cantidad
que hay que recorrer para cumplir un
ciclo y luego la dividimos entre la
rapidez con la que cubrimos los ángulos
de ahí vienen estos dos segundos con
esto podemos pensar en una fórmula que
relacione el periodo y la velocidad
angular el periodo es igual a dos
radiales que es lo que se recorre para
completar un ciclo y esto lo dividimos
entre la rapidez con la que cubrimos los
ángulos con esto relacionamos el periodo
con la velocidad angular si conocemos el
periodo podemos encontrar la frecuencia
de una forma muy directa la frecuencia
es el inverso del periodo ya habíamos
mencionado que la frecuencia es el
recíproco del periodo por lo que la
frecuencia es igual a la omega entre 2
pi en esta situación en la que el
periodo es igual a 2 segundos y no
conocemos el valor de
entonces sabemos que la frecuencia es el
inverso del periodo por lo que será
igual a uno entre dos segundos también
podemos decir que esto es un medio con
unidades de un segundo inverso o hertz
que podemos leer como un medio de ciclo
por segundo si omega spears radiales por
segundo esta pelota se moverá un segundo
dos segundos tres segundos cuatro
segundos aquí podemos ver que el periodo
es de dos segundos y podemos ver que
cada segundo la pelota recorre irradian
es y irradian es es medio ciclo
completamos medio ciclo cada segundo
nos vemos en otro vídeo